thank you for coming to the fifth day
the last day of the workshop the first
uh talk is by Daniel dege uh the title
is towards interpretable data science
Daniel can thank you thanks
suda so I will talk today about
explaining computation and um as we know
machines make crucial decisions even
more so than than they used to and their
decision making is just getting more and
more back uh this means we need
justifications and explanations we need
them for accountability we need them to
identify biases and we need them for
debugging uh multiple Notions of
explanations have been proposed and some
are actually widely used in the industry
for machine learning I'll talk about two
of them one is based on sharly values
and the other is based on counter
factual and um the the main theme of
this talk is that explanations are
needed throughout the data sence science
cycle so what is the data science cycle
um
typically people talk about a phase of
business understanding um combined with
data understanding uh that's an
exploratory step and I will talk about
this um briefly uh then there is a step
of data preparation which includes data
cleaning data integration and so forth
then comes the step of modeling which
takes more most attention although it is
usually claimed that around 80% of the
data scientist's time is actually around
these parts that precede the modeling
and then evaluation and
deployment now um in this talk I will
talk about two facets of inter
interaction between explainable AI
between explanations for machine
learning and
databases uh one facet is ml explanation
techniques for tasks borrowing the
ideas that are successful in the context
of machine learning of explainable AI
and um making them work for database
tasks such as data
Explorations um old school querying and
cleaning uh and the second part of the
talk we talk about a different facet
which is using database techniques to
support and facilitate machine learning
machine learning EXP
explanations uh I will briefly show how
database constraints are useful when
deriving counterfactuals for machine
learning um and I will talk about our
recent work on declarative
counterfactual
management so again I claim that
explanations are needed throughout the
the data science cycle uh and the field
of explainable AI typically focuses
naturally on the AI on the model um when
evaluated and
deployed um and there are two leading
approaches there are many approaches but
there are two leading ones one is called
feature
attribution where the idea is that we
get a classification and we want to
understand why so the why takes the form
of assigning some score to each of the
features of the particular instance that
we are now
classifying and this score should
reflect the contribution to the
classification result and here Shar is a
leading tool companies are actually
using it uh mention what shop is um and
actually that's that's very
useful the other type of explanation
that people are typically interested in
in explainable AI is based on
counterfactuals counterfactuals are
perturbations to the input small changes
to the input they change the
classification results and then it's not
necessarily A change in a particular
feature but rather it's use usually a
combination of features that change the
classification
result um and and these are
complimentary in nature because the
first talks about the contribution of
individual attributes while the L talks
about the contribution of attribute
subsets and then there are many other
approaches that I will not talk about
including approximating the model via a
simple one um and other approaches that
are out
there so um the leading approach
nowadays in expandable AI on feature in
the context of feature attribution uses
the notion called shoply values which is
a notion from Cooperative Game Theory uh
back in the 50s by lloy chapley um and
there it was defined as a way to fairly
distribute reward among players um so if
we have a finite set of players and we
have a game value function for sets of
players essentially any function that
assigns um a number um to a given subset
we Define the sharply value of a player
essentially as its marginal contribution
to subsets which is multiplied by some
Co
efficient Justified which is justified
by um the satisfaction of some axom that
I will talk about um in a minute so
that's a that's a notion that's a
function that assigns values to players
in a game uh in the context of machine
learning the game is the classification
and the players are the features and we
are given an instance in the model and
we wish to assign a score to each
feature which reflects its contribution
to the gug to the prediction and again
the score is based on sharply values
along with some hacks that are needed to
account of the fact that we cannot
really talk about subsets of attributes
in in the model so instead we talk about
subset of attributes completed by uh for
instance the average
value of the other attributes um uh in
some Set uh but the result in the end is
that we get some instance and a
classification and the model output is
04 that's the the confidence of the
model uh in some classification result
for instance uh and then we want an
explanation so this explanation takes
the form of the age contributes point4
and the sex for instance
contributed minus.
three as I said the notion of sharle is
justified by the fact that it satisfies
some very natural
efficiency namely the sum of the sharply
values is the sum of the game is the
value of the game uh that two equal
players that contribute the same to each
to every subset actually will get the
same sharply values and some other
natural axom linearity for instance and
it turns out that if one insists on
these axioms then sharly values are
actually the only way to um assign
values contribution
values to the game uh in a way that
satisfies these
axom so sharly values are both
theoretically satis Justified and are
very commonly used in practice which
means that we should at least look at
them in the context of database
tasks uh and this is further justified
by the fact that we know that queries
for instance may be used for F
engineering so we take a look at this
particular database of transaction and
searches and we want to feature that
that states that some user is interested
in fashion this feature may be
engineered by some complex query and
then we get the featur so sha tells us
that this feature of interested in
fashion contributed a lot but who knows
how this feature was computed and we
want to understand further uh
what goes on in the
computation so to this end LIF sheet
scheld
and other
collaborators have proposed to use
sharly values for tap in query
answering uh where the idea is that the
game value function is the qu result and
the players are Tel and if we look at
the sharly value formula and the we um
use it for Boolean queries so
essentially the game value function is
the query result so if you look at a
particular fact in the database we look
at its contribution to the query result
with respect to each subset of the
database uh and if the query for
instance is non Boolean then we can look
at the residual query with respect to
each output apple and it works the same
it allows us to assign the contribution
value for every input fact with respect
to every output fact so many um uh and
the and the collabor at s they have
initiated a study of sharly values
for database
queries and in the joint work that I
will briefly talk about we um talked
about
computational
aspects namely uh we we have identified
first of all that provenance is very
useful here so just a recap on what is
provenance although I'm sure that in
this room this is not necessary so we
have a database and we have a query say
return all customers with overdraft
events after 2006 or something like that
and we want to know why did we get a
particular result so a particular form
of Y is What's
um known as provenance and in this
setting we have joined P1 with C1 and we
have we could have also gotten this
result by joining P3 and C2 so this is
uh uh provenance and provenance is
actually very useful if you look at this
formula where we want to compute the
query result over subsets provance is
very useful here because it allows us to
read the the query results over subset
efficiently from the provenance without
having to reevaluate the query over each
subset so we know that the provenance is
satisfied for a particular
set if sorry that the query is satisfied
for a particular subset if the
Providence is satisfied for the truth
assignment that assigns through to the
variables annotating the tles in s and
false to all other variables so then we
can read these um the sharly values we
can compute
the the intermediate
results directly from the
provenant moreover H this leads to a
reduction to Sharp Set uh so that's that
may be of interest in this workshop on
logic um so observe that if we look at
the circuit that represents the
provenant and then we look at two
circuits obtained by setting either zero
or one to the particular fact are
interested in F then what we get here is
that actually all subsets of the same
size contribute um the same to the
formula so we can actually take this out
and compute sharp set K which is the
number of satisfying assignments with
exactly K variables that are set to
True uh and if we know this number for
CF equals 1 and we know this number for
c fals z then we can actually compute
the sharply
values of course Computing sharp set k
for a circuit is a difficult task uh and
we know from the theoretical results by
Benny and collaborators we know the chly
value computation is generally hard and
they have established a beautiful
dichotomy result on when it is
tractable uh what we did in this um
joint sigot
paper is to uh develop a a a a
practically efficient approach that
first compiles the provenance into a
circuit then applies a second step of
knowledge compilation
of the circuit and then applies the
exact algorithm over the compiled
circuit to comput the sharly values when
this is possible sometimes compilation
fails or is too slow and then we propose
a way for an inexact computation for a
proxy function which allows us to rank
the sharply Val the influence without
actually Computing the sharply
values so very briefly um knowledge
compilers we have used them in this
setting to compile to a particular form
called deterministic and decomposable
circuits and we say that an endgate is
decomposable for each two input Gates we
get that they do not share variables and
then or gate is deterministic if there
is no assignment that satisfies both
sides of the
orgate uh and for a deterministic and
decomposable circuit we can actually
compute in polinomial time the set the
sharp sat K value uh for all case
essentially via dynamic
programming the trouble is that of
course we cannot always efficiently
compile into a deterministic and
decomposable circuit uh our experiments
show that it works for some what of 85%
of the output apples for tpch and for
most output t for IMDb where the queries
are simpler in a sense uh so this we've
implemented using c2d and uh again it
works fairly well but there are cases
where um it just fails it it time outs
it times out or runs out of memory and
so
forth um there are a few more steps to
make this uh uh work okay for instance
the c2d expects CNF as input so we need
the satin transform to transform into
CNF um and there are all kind of
technicalities to address in this um
setting and then we get this 85% for
tpch and 99% for
IMDb for these cases where the
compilation is too costly or May Fail uh
we can actually resort to ranking
instead of computing the actual sharly
values we can try to rank to to to
decide which of the facts influenced
more than the others without actually
Computing the exact sharly
values uh and we do that via eristics
which essentially instead of looking at
the CNF itself we look at at the proxy
function uh which in essentially if you
think about the conjunction as a
multiplication of
the value function for the different
Clauses we look at the sum of the
Clauses so intuitively we look at how
many Clauses were
satisfied um and thanks to the sharp
linearity property to compute sharply
values with respect to this function is
much more effic efficient and can be
performed in linear time now of course
what we get is not the sharply values of
the real function it can actually be
arbitrarily off uh but it turns out that
in practice and in many cases what we
get here is actually very close to the
real um to the real values for instance
the Precision at five is is typically
almost
one we can you can also uh propose a
hybrid computation which is what we
propose in practice essentially start by
running the exact computation algorithm
and if if it completes successfully in
under 10 seconds just returns it results
otherwise um terminate the exact
computation give up on exact values and
resort to this ranking and this is an
approach that's actually very uh
effective in practice because what we
have observed is that if you Su if the
algorithm succeeds it's it typically
succeeds quite fast like in two and a
half seconds so after this threshold we
can just resort to a a a ranking without
guarantees when we have this ranking or
a computation of sharly values depending
on how the provenance looks like uh we
can essentially combine it with the
classical provenance views because you
see like I said before there is um I
talked about it in the context of
counterfactual but it holds also in the
context of queries sharly values their
power is that they allow to quantify the
result of each individual contributor so
they're very simple in a sense to to
visualize we can see that the fact that
Alice bought this item was actually very
influential so it's easy to to
communicate the
explanation on the other hand it's very
partial because this fact did not stand
on its own it stands together with other
facts so uh what we have proposed we
have developed a system called Shar
graph which actually allows two views
together so we can we can we visualize
the provence graph in the standard form
of a circuit but we also highlight in
each for each node of the graph it's
individual contribution and the users
can actually go back and forth between
these views of individual contribution
and Joint contribution via provenance
graphs so so that's another view of the
of the system you see the circuit with
lots of nodes but then you can also see
um according to the color code you can
see which nodes contributed the most and
you can actually H hover over them and
see what their contribution is so that's
a mixed view of joint and individual
contribution all right back to the data
science cycle so um we talked about data
preparation in a sense in the of feature
engineering that may be used VR querying
there are other facets of data
preparation for instance data cleaning
and data
repair um and again that's actually
something that's very um um that data
scientists care a lot about uh we have
developed a system called T-Rex that
uses sharly values to qu quantify the
contribution of each cell and constraint
to each repair um and this can work on
any blackbox repair algorithm we've used
it for in particular for holoc clean
which is commonly used for data
cleaning um of course the main issue is
performance Shar itself is not optimized
for this kind of task and does not scale
so we need to develop some ping tics and
to use them in conjunction with
sampling but the end result is that we
get a database and we have some
rules that it
violates so then holoc or any other
system um recommends
fix uh and we want to know what
contributed to this fix so T-Rex can
actually say well this cell contributed
the most in this case to this particular
fix so we can know that this was the
main reason for the fix and of course
it's a a marginalized view in the sense
that we marginalize the contribution of
each individual cell while in practice
multiple cells contributed together so
it's a complementary to other
approaches if we go further to the data
understanding uh phase of the data
science
cycle um here people T typically talk
about exploratory data analysis so what
is exploratory data analysis or Eda uh
it's a common preliminary step in data
science which involves looking at
different views of the data and it's not
necessarily a particular analysis goal
in mind you don't have necessarily a
query in mind but rather you're just
looking for insights which is a very
fuzzy
concept uh and then actually data
scientists regularly publish the
notebooks that record the exploratory
steps and the intermediate results and
that's something that other scientists
are interested in because if they look
at the same data set they want to know
what insights others found them and
there are two challenges for the uh
first part for find
the insights that's hard of course but
then also understanding the notebooks
that other published is also
hard uh so we've developed a system that
explains data
exploration um you can think about a
particular example where you have a data
set about flight delays that's analyzed
in notebooks and then other analysts
look at this notebook and try to
understand what was going on so our
systems automatically generates
explanations for the interesting parts
of the views now what's the interesting
part of the view that's of course
debatable but there are some standard
interestingness
measures um that are typically used
actually for recommending steps in Eda
such
as is the view diverse does
it exhibit some diverse phenomena or
exceptionality and other kinds of um
interestingness measures so what we've
did here is again we looked at chly
values as means to quantify the
contribution of each Tel to the
interestingness measure essentially not
just saying this view is interesting
because it has high diversity but rather
uh what contributed to this High
diversity so we have this database of
flights and the analyst filtered the the
table to find flights with duration
that's greater than 90 and they got
something and they published a notebook
and that it but we want to know why what
what was interesting in the generated
view so um again we have this uh like I
said these interestingness measure so we
compute multiple interesting measures
for each view uh those commonly found in
the literature and then we find the topk
elements that contribute the most to the
interestingness of the view and we use
the sharply value to rank the
contribution of each
element and then we are some more guys
pets for instance some hardcoded natural
language patterns we can actually autod
document notebooks with comments such as
well the major deviation occurs on the
on this group where this attribute value
change from this value to this
one and we can actually embed this in
the notebook itself so we see the filter
operation and then we say well the view
shows high exceptionality so that's the
interestingness measure
that we get from previous works but we
further specify that specifically the
major deviation and that was was the
major contributor to this High
exceptionality okay so so far we've
talked about ml explanation results
techniques for DB tasks specifically
taking sharly values all the way back in
the
analysis and uh in the next few minutes
I want to talk about another aspect
which is using database techniques for
machine learning
explanations here I want to talk about a
different approach which is that of
counter factual which is as I said our
perturbations to the input that change
the classification results and like I
said it's complementary to sharly
values so counter effectual actually
there is a recent survey that CES
hundreds of works on counter facture
generation in the context of machine
learning it's a very
vibrant area of research it's highly
useful both for explaining individual
predic predictions which was the use
case that I talked about in the context
of Shar so we have a prediction we want
to understand why we can either give um
quantify the contribution of each
individual feature or quantify or or say
these features together were very
influential uh on the other hand it's
typically slower to compute in this use
case than sharp which is why sharp is
typically preferred for this use case on
the other hand it's highly useful for
explaining the model as a whole and I
want to show you two U or three rather
very common examples so the first is
lime I I imagine that some of you heard
of it uh that's a work from University
of
Washington uh and the main idea is that
one samples perturbed instance around
some instance X of um interest and then
um these are weighed according to the
their distance and we retrieve the
predictions on these pert instances so
some of them are counterfactual some of
them are actually perturbations that
behave like that were classified like
the original
instance now we learn a linear model
that approximates the model well in the
in the proximity of this particular
Point not necessarily in general and
then we highlight for instance super
pixels in the context of images with
positive weights towards this class in
the linear model so then the highlighted
super pixels the highlighted part of the
image actually highlight what was
interesting and and the the parts of the
image that were most influential in the
decisions of the
model so that's one way to use
counterfactuals um to analyze the model
as a whole there's another War called
certify uh that actually looks at the
magnitude of the required perturbations
to quantify the model fairness
essentially the idea is that if a
particular group particular minority for
instance uh not only is
classified more negatively but rather
needs to change more to be classified
positively then that's a sign of
unfairness so if the magnitude of of the
minimal coun effectual if the magnitude
of changes that I need to pass the
classifier are are is is higher for this
particular group that's called the
burden in this work then this um the
this indicates unfairness towards this
group and then there is a this area of
research called algorithmic recourse
where the idea is to find not only
counterfactuals but rather action
actionable counterfactuals for instance
if you raise your salary by 100K then
your loan request would be
approved so these are three ideas on how
to use counterfactuals for model
analysis um and I claim the database
constraints are actually very useful in
each of these scenarios uh and the point
is that these counter effectual are
often hypothetical instances and not
necessarily real ones and to be of
interest they should be realistic right
so for instance a counterfactual
instance that changes the country but
keeps the city
intact is not a very useful recourse
telling you stay in Tel Aviv but move to
the USA that's not a very useful
recommendation and it's also problematic
if you want to use it as a training
instance and that's the kind of
information that we can get from
database constraints we can know that
that kind of counter effectual is
actually
impossible so we have Incorporated in
the computation of counterfactuals we
have Incorporated different kinds of
database Integrity constraints such as
domain constraint check constraint
conditional functional dependencies and
un denial constraints and we have
derived them for the same databases that
people use in the machine learning
training and then we've developed a
fairly simple algorithm which
essentially tries to perturb tries to
find the
counterfactual if this counterfactual
actually violates the constraints that
are marked here in this yellow rectangle
uh then we do a
projection once we did the projection
then maybe we are back to this blue area
that we started started with we wanted a
counterfactual that would lead us to the
red one so then we need to perturb again
and project again and that's completely
euristic but in practice it leads us
after a small number of steps to a point
that's actually both in the area of
classification that we want and in this
rectangle meaning it's um useful um it
satisfies the constraints so I I'll skip
the details of how that's done and I
just show you that actually when we use
constraints and retrain a model we get
better results than just retraining it
on counter factur that ignore the con D
Daniel could could you wrap up in one or
two minutes yes yes absolutely
absolutely
yeah so uh the last thing I want to show
and that's the perfect for this two
minutes uh is uh our recent work on
counterfactual databases and that's
another example of how to use databases
for for uh machine learning
analysis so the point here is that
counterfactual generation is actually
computationally costly and it's
computationally costly especially when
it's constrained and especially when we
need counter factur for many instances
like we do in this scenario of model
analysis rather than explaining a single
prediction so we have developed a system
called the cfdb which includes a
declarative language for CF based
analysis it allows to interact with a CF
generator Oracle so any one of the
algorithms of the the 100 Al algorithms
that I have mentioned before and
optimize the trade-off between CF
generation and reuse essentially the
idea is that if we have already in the
database a counterfactual that's in the
proximity of the instance we are
interested in we can avoid calling the
counterfactual generator and we can also
anticipate this and reorder the calls to
the generators so that we will have
counterfactuals to reuse so so that's a
simple example and I'll wrap up with
that of
cfq uh so we can specify which
predictions we're interested in in this
case false negatives ones for which the
ground proof is accepted but the label
is rejected from the training data uh
and we can specify what kind of
counterfactuals we're interested in in
this case counterfactuals that keep the
home status intact but increase the
income the semantics is that then we
compile the constraint into booing EXP
ations find counterfactuals that satisfy
these constraints and store the results
in the
database once we have them these in the
database so we have in particular these
instances corresponding to these predi
predictions which are false
negatives we can actually know what kind
of counter factures we are interested in
and that's actually via C tables so via
compiling the query into
you using the c table algorithm to
evaluate the query we can reach a a
bullant condition such as the home
status should be own and the income
should be greater than 80 that's one
counterfactual we're interested in and
another one is where the rent the home
status is rent and the income is greater
than
60 so that's passed on to counter
factual generators there are many of
them that know how to get buen
Expressions as
constraints and we get a result um one
other example is to use the C fql for
certify again here we're interested in
uh changes that do not change the race
in gender but rather change other
features and with under the hood
optimizations we are able to
significantly speed up the CF based
analysis uh in particular we can get the
same conclusions as certify uh much
faster uh if we by controlling a reuse
threshold which is a user controlled
parameter deciding whether to reuse
counterfactuals rather than invoking the
counterfactual generator again and
again so just to conclude um
explainability is extensively studied in
both the database and machine learning
communities we need explanations for
different components of the data science
cycles and these Solutions should
interact the sharly values that are
useful for machine learning may be
useful foration across the boards uh if
we have database constraints we should
account for them when generating machine
learning counterfactuals and if we have
explanations and we have a database we
might as well store the explanations in
a database analyze them and use uh the
beautiful techniques from declarative
databases to optimize the
analysis thank
you is there one very quick question for
Daniel before uh we move to
Amir
thanks for the talk um do you have any
idea whether maybe shapely values uh
could be extended for queries with
agregation do you think there's any hope
or yeah so many so then
walk you Daniel one second please uh uh
could you stop sharing and Amir can
share and then you can
answer
yeah yeah so aggregation is a very
interesting question Benny had some
beautiful theoretical results about it
maybe wants to answer and uh I don't
think there is actually a practical
system implementation for shly for
agregates me if I'm wrong
Benny are
theoretical results that extend we have
bull points I'll talk about it I mean
the I'll answer the question in my
okay okay let's discuss more when we
have the discussion session